throughout the late 19th and early 20th
centuries nationalism became a dominant
force in global politics it saw many
peoples including the Germans the
Italians the poles the Bulgarians the
Romanians and the Turks amongst many of
those carve out national territories in
which they and their people could live
this was because those people saw
themselves in their neighbors as being
part of a homogeneous group this idea
that the same people should live in a
single United political entity was also
found throughout the Middle East and
expressed itself in what's called
pan-arabism
since this never happened the question
is why not and how close did the
pan-arab East dream come to fruition
well the idea of the unified Arab world
started to be taken seriously in the
late 19th century in opposition to
Ottoman rule during the First World War
many of these Arab nationalists rebelled
against the Ottoman Empire and work with
the antón powers to establish an
independent Arab state the on Tom had
agreed to this but after the war was
over no as such Arab nationalism zame
continued to be the removal of imperial
powers from their lands and these
nationalists were given outside help
mostly from Egypt in Iraq it wasn't
until after World War Two in the
collapse of British and French rule in
the region that pan-arabism really
started to pick up with the cold war
raging onwards both the USA and USSR
were looking to expand their influence
in the region and for many there this
wasn't on because much of the pan
Arabist ideology focused on removing all
foreign influence from the region it was
also at this point that the overwhelming
majority of Arab leaders barring Lebanon
backed the creation of an Arab state yet
this alone wasn't enough and here we can
learn from the unification of Germany
since unification was supported by most
German leaders and the German people too
yet it required several wars to achieve
and the reason why is that much like
Arab leaders the Germans agreed that the
state should be made yet they couldn't
agree on who would lead it so 1958
arguably saw the height of Arab
nationalism when two attempts were made
at building an Arab state the first saw
Egypt and Syria merged to become the
United Arab Republic under Egyptian
President Gamal Abdul Nasser the
unification came about after the people
of Syria got a big communist II thus the
Syrian leadership approached NASA to
unify the states and put down any
potential issues there were several
problems though the first was that Syria
was mostly turned into an Egyptian
colony Nia had listen to no voice in the
Union and also whilst Nasser was no
friend of communism he wasn't exactly
protective of the business interests of
Syria's leaders and after numerous
economic reforms they decided that this
was a
my idea in in 1961 Siri declared its
independence
the second arab state of 1958 was the
Arab Federation made from the merger of
Iraq and Jordan whose kings were cousins
now this union went nowhere because both
had wildly different interests an IVA
could decide on who would be in charge
not that the question mattered for long
as it's Faisal the second the king of
Iraq was deposed in a coup shortly
afterwards after this there was one more
notable attempt in this was in 1971 when
a coup in Libya place more amo Gaddafi
in charge who promptly proposed a union
with Egypt Sudan and Syria this was
backed by both the leaders and peoples
of these countries but it fell apart
where nobody could decide on the details
notably who would be in charge and
ultimately it's this reason why the
creation of an Arab state failed the
public backing had always been there and
the region's leaders had always pushed
for the unification of the Arab world
the problem was that they all thought
that they were going to be the ones to
lead it
combine this with differing foreign
policy goals particularly between the
pro-west in Iraq and the pro-soviet
Egypt and things get even more
complicated and it was these outside
backers who had an interest in
preventing the unification of the Arab
world since a unified Arab state would
certainly have been a formidable global
power and at the height of the Cold War
nobody wanted the competition I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with the special thanks to my
patreon supporters James Bissonnette
Colin Castleman danny Maloney Marvin
Castle Rob Waterhouse John BJ's Mo Aaron
the white Michael Reynolds James
Castaneda Gustav Swan Marcus Ozma Jordan
Longley James Castaneda Gustav Swan
Marcus Ozma Jordan Hong Lei Gareth
Turner mr. show Rashid Ali spinning
three plates filled to oink-oink David
Silverman Izzy
Winston Cawood Maggie packs Kowski Lexi
Schwinn Spencer Lightfoot Kelly
moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell and Anthony
Beckett